yeah a new game against Alex from from
Germany doesn't have a name in there I
guess oh hi it's got a name in them some
someone from not too far away I don't
know him really but um it's a regional
player so while we got the sloth let's
play Nancy 3 i'm not sure what's coming
86 yeah let's go g 3 this was um chrome
next choice recently and um in London
against Luke McShane and it led to some
interesting play what this I mean I can
just take right so there's some some
trick I don't think it can sec the
exchange in this position quite often
you can not often but sometimes you can
do that okay now of course the light is
hanging so I need to reach read them
yeah but this whole procedure only let
them to a week poll on c forum yeah now
the white square saw the light squares
are complete complete disaster okay
let's take it of course i wanted to
initiate to UM fianchetto but them it's
not possible anymore yeah just Queenie
for get this in a pin yeah what the
disaster very quick very quick game yeah
probably mb5 he overlooked something
essential here now it's just um it's
just gone and doesn't have a move really
can we go sir 27 for example just Bishop
b5
and black explodes so just not v5 is
simply not not not a playable move what
he probably needs to do is some play and
play something like ecigs it always it
looks a bit passive yum this kind of
move but you need two unique your bishop
which is a bit passive to protect the
light square so you cannot afford any
luxuries like I don't know Bishop f5 or
something cannot simply cannot do that
after Bishop g2 and 95 I'll get this
pawn anyway and then this Bishop is just
not protecting the Queen side so yeah
very quickly knock out here after b5 but
still okay a warning for for the opening
for black um and this line here was g3 I
mean this is something you can have a
look at for white it's a quite an
interesting way to to play this position
you need to be ready to at some point
maybe sacrifice a pawn on c4 it's
similar to to a Catalan that done it
needs to fresh positions that are not so
typical of the a6 online and this is far
less some work um theoretical work that
you need to do in compared to III rc5
especially or a for those other big
moves yeah thanks for watching this
short video admittedly